I wish everyone would just shut up about
seed oils
okay okay here we go
one two three
oh no
um
well I hate them I love talking about
them you like talking about I'm this is
a kind of a somewhat recent conversion
for me I've never bought into any diet
fad or any of these hippie
seed oils are of the devil they are the
cause of every problem in the world wow
almost almost I would say 99 I am so
I'm so one over on this now your wife is
a doctor so obviously you know that well
I mean I assumed it was crap but then I
just missed it like every other stupid
idea that I ever heard
also I'm sick of people making products
from things that that don't produce that
product naturally like like oats are not
for milk and and I never get down on it
and neither neither are almonds and
neither are soybeans no as it turns out
none of these things produce milk and so
if you give me a glass of milk that is
made from a thing that doesn't produce
milk I'm suspicious if it doesn't have
Udders right like olives produce oil and
seeds generally do not produce oil so I
don't know what seed oil is or do you
know what you know what canola oil
actually is oh no it's called rapeseed
wow it is it is that's the name all the
others what soybean oil all these other
oils that that are
and when you want to stop using them you
can't they're in every food they're in
every single food I saw one I was
perhaps turning the frogs gay like
probably yeah I I looked at one product
in the grocery store are they making the
chicken sterile well that in fire a fire
is also turning the chicken
I'm turning them to like crispy little
nuggets on their in their hatcheries not
the avian flu
but I I was in a grocery store and they
had a thing of some seed oil nonsense
and it said it called it plant butter
plant butter where do you get the butter
from this is no that's terrible that's
terrible yeah okay well let me drink to
that there's no seed oil in my Martini
that's for sure
no there might be in the peanut butter
okay
I'm taller
but we can't stand up too I'm taller
it's I'm taller so you have to say do I
agree with that statement oh do you
agree with the statement that you are
taller yes but who is the eye right
exactly the objective becomes very yeah
I'm I'm taller so you should right it's
the answer as though as I said right
correct okay ready get set go
oh I think we're going to have to move
that really you think you're taller oh
yeah but you certainly think that you're
taller because all guys absolutely every
guy under six foot at least under six
foot is will you'll they'll say hey how
tall are you and you say like I'm 5
10.034 that's true I'm practicing it
totally depends also on how you're
wearing your hair so right now you are
wearing like a pompadour you've got like
the John Kerry you've got at least four
inches here yes I do I mean like it's
like a beehive from the 1960s
they're actual creatures living there
there are yes sweet little groupies like
from the 1960s yeah there's like a rat
under there and it's controlling how you
cook yeah one more Height please give me
a little okay
we'll never know until the game is over
and then we'll be lying down on the
floor just sloshed I was hoping to
finish the sentence in that way okay
here we go
Satanism is protected under the First
Amendment
okay ready I what I think you're gonna
say what do you think I'm gonna say but
I'm actually somewhat unsure of what you
would say yeah
okay ready get set no
so you're welcome you're correct I don't
think Satanism is protected under the
First Amendment the first amendment is
for political speech yeah that is what
it is for and by the way it's not
protected on the state level it's
protected first of all I don't believe
in the incorporation Doctrine so there's
that for people who don't okay so the
First Amendment of the United States
Constitution says Congress shall make no
law abridging the freedom of speech it
does not say anything about States
making laws abridging the freedom of
speech now many states have their own
Provisions along these lines but
abridgement of speech are
extraordinarily common at the local and
and City level even at the state level
role of American History right exactly
the the notion the founders were sitting
around like we have to protect the
satanists the satanists must be
protected is is absolute absurdity they
wouldn't have considered it freedom of
speech they would have considered it
essentially the same as pornography I
think yeah um and so I I would have a
hard time believing that the founders
were sitting around being like we have
to protect Satanism yeah and and so
especially not under freedom of religion
which they would have thought freedom of
religion encompassed you know known
religions it didn't Encompass things
like worship of the devil we were just
talking about John Locke who he has this
he gets a worse rap than he deserves
because he's sometimes described as the
he's not Jon Stewart Mill they make him
out like he's Jon Stewart yes yeah and
he's he's really not and especially in
the the essay concerning Toleration uh
Locke says we need free speech everyone
needs to have some free speech except
for those damn dirty atheists who should
be totally ostracized from society kind
of based you know based John alrighty
foreign
[Music]